ya son varios los camiones que han
pasado tanto del lado colombiano hacia
Venezuela como de Venezuela hacia
Colombia por este que es el puente
internacional Simón Bolívar que conecta
al municipio de Villa del Rosario en el
departamento de norte de Santander con
el estado táchira del lado venezolano
esto como un primer paso para la
normalización de relaciones entre
Colombia y Venezuela anunciada por los
presidentes el acto protocolario Tuvo
una duración bastante corta a unos 15
minutos el presidente Gustavo Petro hizo
presencia aquí con tres de sus ministros
y adicionalmente con las autoridades
locales para hacer esta reapertura y en
medio también de bastantes personas
alrededor de mil o 1500 personas se
congregaron aquí en la frontera para
celebrar este el reinicio de una nueva
relación entre Colombia y Venezuela
entre las principales puntos que se
pueden destacar del discurso de Gustavo
Petro fue él él ha prometió que no va a
continuar esta lo que ha llamado una ca
fue humanitaria entre ambos países por
el cierre de las fronteras parcial hace
siete años
total hace siete años y parcial hace
tres años dice que va a luchar contra el
contrabando que ha sido el Común
denominador entre ambos partes de la
frontera y que se espera que en los
próximos años se logre un intercambio
comercial de alrededor de 8.000 millones
de dólares también anunció la apertura
en las próximas semanas del puente de
tienditas Este es un puente ubicado a
unos 20 minutos de acá que servirá para
el transporte de carga y para el
transporte de pasajeros lo cierto Es que
hoy apenas comienza todo este proceso
falta todavía habilitar el paso de
transporte público y también de
transporte municipal y eso es lo que
esperan los habitantes los más de 30.000
personas que pasan por esta frontera
todos los días en una frontera común que
es de unos 2.200 kilómetros y que se
abre hoy definitivamente ha dicho el
presidente Gustavo Petro